bonjour à tous Un nouvel épisode de Loki
vient de sortir et vous savez ce que ça
veut dire c'est la sortie d'une nouvelle
vidéo analyse pour comprendre tous les
détails de ce dernier avant ça je vous
invite quand même à voir la review de
l'épisode 1 histoire d'être à jour et
sinon ne tardons pas plus longtemps
voyons ce que nous amène l'épisode 2 la
scène d'ouverture nous amène directement
dans le flux temporel sacré et plus
exactement à Londres en
1977 tout comme l'avait annoncé l'
épisode précédent loky est à la
recherche de Sylvie pour comprendre la
fameuse vision du futur dont il a été
victime à cause du Time sleeping
néanmoins il n'est pas le seul à vouloir
la trouver la général DOX et le Chasseur
X5 sont également sur sa piste mais
contre toute attente X5 a
mystérieusement déserté et a décidé de
reprendre sa vie d'origine dans le flux
temporel eloki Mobius ainsi que B1 ont
besoin de savoir ce que Brad trame
réellement en zouant sur la situation
l'épisode 2 de loky aussi fourni soit-il
sert avant tout à mettre en place et à
jour les problématiques dont font face
nos personnages principaux de la même
manière que l'épisode 1 de la première
saison où Mobius remettait en question
la vie et les intentions de Loki sous
forme d'interrogatoire ici le procédé
est réutilisé par le biais d'ex5 avec
Mobius etoki sincèrement c'était je
trouve une scène dont nous avions besoin
qui va permettre de poser et des bases
et des directions pour le futur de la
série en fait au tout début de la
première saison quand Mobius interroge
lcky il va surtout le déconstruire tout
ce que nous avons connu dans les trois
premières phases concernant Loki c'est
désormais du passé aujourd'hui le
personnage doit évoluer et prendre une
autre direction et de l'autre côté comme
on en avait parlé bah Mobius servait de
stabilité il était notre référence
concernant le TVA aujourd'hui tout a
changé celui qui demeure a été découvert
puis tué les mensonges du TVA ont été
révélés les problématiques ne sont plus
les mêmes donc celle de nos personnages
également Loki est clairement dans une
phase où Marvel je pense souhaite
redorer son blason ce que je veux dire
par là Brad l'a d'ailleurs bien dit
c'est que Loki depuis toujours dans le
MCU c'est un raté un véritable perdant
il échoue à chaque fois ses émotions
prennent très souvent le pas sur sa
raison il se pense exceptionnel mais il
ne l'est pas et pire que ça c'est un
vilain de comics un vulgaire méchant en
gros sauf qu'il a vécu sa déconstruction
dans la première saison loky a franchi
plusieurs étapes jusqu'à finalement
réussir à atteindre la fin des temps et
maintenant après avoir évolué et compris
les enjeux Marvel nous montre une
nouvelle facette du personnage on l'a vu
hein dans les deux premiers épisodes et
la course poursuite avec Brad transpiré
complètement de ça Loki et badasse tout
en gardant son essence de vilain prête à
faire d'horribles choses comme il le dit
Loki est désormais une force et une
stabilité dans ce TVA déchiré j'avance
un peu dans l'épisode sans trop
détailler mais il est celui qui va
réconforter Mobius il est celui qui va
faire plier Brad il est celui qui va
réunir en ramenant Sylvie et le plus
fort restera quand même la fin de
l'épisode alors que le TVA vit un
véritable drame celui au centre de
l'image à aller au devant positionné
au-dessus des autres tout en posant sa
main sur l'épaule de Mobius comme pour
symboliser un pilier et bien c'est Loki
tous ces symboles sont très forts et si
Marvel a voulu développer ceci c'est
pour une bonne raison en fait il y a un
autre point intéressant dont nous devons
nous rappeler mais c'est que Loki ainsi
que Sylvie ont été choisis par celui qui
demeure pour prendre sa place Loki a
donc une place toute particulière dans
ce qui a été prévu par l'ancien
directeur du TVA c'est un véritable
sujet à théorie qui nous pousserait à
s'éloigner de notre analyse de l'épisode
mais tout ça pour vous dire que Loki a
un véritable rôle à jouer et ce que nous
a proposé les deux premiers épisodes
pour le moment pousse clairement à
l'unicité et au démarquage du dieu de la
malice d'ailleurs j'ai mal pensé mais
Marvel aurait pu choisir n'importe quel
autre personnage pour faire une série
sur le TVA pourtant ils ont choisi de
développer Loki et de le mettre au cœur
de la série la plus importante et
explicative de cette nouvelle saga en
fait quand on connaît le personnage de
Kang le conquérant et bien on se rend
compte que Loki s'en approche quand même
pas mal en réalité tout ce qu'a dit
brade concernant Loki chose qu'il a déjà
entendu d'ailleurs de la bouche de celui
qui demeure dans la première saison et
bien cela s'applique aussi à Kang par
exemple dans les comics Kang dans ses
premières années c'est finalement un
simple vilain relié au voyage dans le
temps il ne fait que perdre face aux
Avengers il a même déjà été tué à
quelques reprises et encore pire souvent
ces défaites c'est dû à ses émotions qui
prennent le dessus sur sa raison sa
colère son égoïsme ou encore son
complexe de supériorité sont au final
tous les véritables ennemis de Kang cela
devrait du coup vous rappeler quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui a d'ailleurs toujours été
convaincu bizarrement d'avoir un destin
glorieux donc voilà cela devrait quand
même nous promettre de belles
interactions entre Loki et celui qui
demeure dans les événements à venir et
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
revenons maintenant à l'épisode petit
détail que je trouve surprenant c'est
que Brad a retrouvé sa vie dans le flux
temporel sacré sauf que vous le savez
les employés du TVA sont tous des
variants ce qui signifie que leur
personne originelle si on peut les
appeler comme ça ça occupe déjà une
place là-bas la preuve en est avec Ren
Slayer quand B1 veut prouver que cette
dernière est une variante elle va guider
les minutes m du TVA dans le flux
temporel sacré et nous montrer que cette
dernière est normalement une
institutrice du coup bah on peut se le
demander qu'est-il arrivé au bras
d'origine est-ce que X5 l'a tué ou s'en
est simplement débarrassé vu que Mobus
le tquine sur le fait qu'il sera oublié
s'il ne reprend pas sa carrière d'acteur
et bien cela veut donc dire que personne
ne pourra prendre sa place alors que
pourtant chacun a normalement un rôle et
une place dans le flux temporel comme
nous le rappelle la discussion entre
Loki et Mobius d'ailleurs donc voilà
cela sous-entendrait que Brad a tué son
autre lui pour prendre sa place et tant
qu'on est sur Brad en parlant de sa
carrière justement toute cette histoire
cache une belle référence au comics Brad
Wolf est un véritable personnage là-bas
c'est un acteur de film et zagak et son
plus grand rôle un tueur en série sauf
qu'une entité extradimensionnelle
provenant de la dimension noire va
posséder l'acteur à succès le poussant à
véritablement devenir
leagnac mais dans la vraie vie et durant
le moment à Londres en 1977 nous pouvons
d'ailleurs noter également la présence
d'un poster de film mettant en vedette
Kingo des éternels célèbre acteur
bollywoodien à cette période bref par la
suite grâce à l'interrogatoire nos
personnages vont finalement retrouver la
trace de Sylvie dans une branche du flux
temporel sacré comme on pouvait s'y
attendre cette dernière embrasse
désormais la liberté et souhaite laisser
cours au libre arbitre quitte à ce que
cela déclenche le véritable chaos Loki
bien évidemment va mentionner le futur
qu'il a vu et à partir de ce moment
quelque chose d'intéressant fait son
apparition nous sommes face au paradoxe
de prédestination mais un paradoxe de
prédestination conscientisé par Loki en
fait c'est la question du destin qui est
remis en jeu peu importe ce que l'on va
faire même en ayant conscience du futur
nos actions nous guideront toujours à ce
moment précis tout est déjà écrit en
quelque sorte et Loki en a bien
conscience mais pas Sylvie qui a juste
titre nous rappelle qu'elle a tué celui
qui demeure la personne qui avait
ordonné le flux temporel sacré sauf
qu'il est là le cœur du problème nous
avions parlé des boucles temporelles du
premier épisode mais en réalité toute la
série loky et je dirais même la saga du
multiver est une gigantesque boucle
celui qui demeure nous avait prévenu
face à ces variants il a vécu et gagner
par la suite la guerre multiverselle lui
permettant après d'empêcher le flux de
se libérer mais s'il n'est plus là pour
diriger le chaos recommence de nouvelles
branches naissent donc de nouveaux
variants et le même scénario se relance
une nouvelle guerre multiversel guerre
multiverselle qu'il gagnera donc avec le
paramètre de boucle celui qui demeure
est prédestiné à gagner et donc devenir
celui qui est encore là à la fin des
temps et d'ailleurs le fonctionnement du
TVA nous le prouve alors qu'ouroboros
tente tout pour réajuster le cœur
temporel il se retrouve bloqué car seul
celui qui a conçu les portes du cœur
peut les ouvrir grâce à son AAT temporel
celui qui demeure a en fait tout
organisé seul lui même après sa mort
peut gérer le TVA ce qui sous-entend que
possiblement seule une version plus
jeune du personnage qui entre autres
n'est pas encore celui qui demeure a les
capacités d'ouvrir les portes c'est
comme si le trône n'était en fait
destiné qu'à une seule personne et par
rapport à tout ça nous pouvons également
souligner l'impact de Miss minut pareil
Miss minut est capable d'ouvrir les
portes et gérer le TVA comme il nous l'a
été expliqué à plusieurs reprises sauf
que cette dernière est fidèle à celui
qui demeure et pire que ça vu que c'est
unea elle est intemporelle et comme il
nous l'a été montré dans la fin de la
saison 1 elle a été programmé à un
moment donné pour guider ravona ravona
qui nous le savons a finalement rejoint
celui qui demeure par conséquent Miss
minut programmé par celui qui demeure va
guider son lui plus jeune à reprendre sa
place et donc reprendre le TVA Unia
conçu par son lui du futur capable de
guider son lui du passé comme ça la même
route est suivie et la boucle est
respectée est-ce que j'ai été clair en
vrai n'hésitez pas à me faire des
retours dans les commentaires la fin de
l'épisode nous indique d'ailleurs que
ravona a été détecté et vu tout ce qui a
été introduit bah si on retrouve ravona
on trouve également celui qui demeure
ainsi que Miss minut donc le prochain
épisode devrait clairement envoyer du
lourd j'ai personnellement très hâte
terminons maintenant sur le cas de la
général DOX comme annoncé dans l'épisode
1 les gardiens du temps sont fake mais
les mises en garde ne le sont pas par
conséquent cette dernière souhaite
continuer délaguer les branches du flux
temporel sacré démontrant au passage la
profonde déchirure au sein du TVA en
réalité je pense que cette scène a un
but de démonstration ce que vient de
faire la Générale DOX aussi horrible
soit-il ne changera rien à terme la
ramification si elle n'est pas
entretenue va reprendre et les branches
vont renaître nous en avons la preuve
toute façon avec la vision du futur qu'
du biloki dans le premier épisode DOX a
simplement gagné du temps et permis de
localiser rensleyer finalement vu qu'il
y avait moins de branches temporelles à
analyser et petit détail nous pouvons
voir que toutes les branches étaient
issues de l'univers 616 l'univers
principal évidemment que nous suivons
depuis le tout premier film de la saga
bref nous allons nous arrêter ici
j'espère de tout cœur que la vidéo vous
a plu je vous ai proposé pas mal
d'apartés pendant l'analyse mais
l'épisode 2 est était vraiment orienté
pour nous faire cogiter sur des sujets
plus globaux n'hésitez pas à partager
vos ressentis en commentaire je les lis
tous et sur ce bah on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour parler de
l'épisode 3 les amis c'était argorck que
le lion heart soit avec vous allez ciao
tout le
[Musique]
monde